Speaker 1: Now I want to get to some absolutely
mind blowing audio. This is like an example of
some of the worst of the worst of corporate
response to a crisis. NPR's Ari Shapiro
interview, interview, interview and interviewed
Neil Potts, Facebook's VP for trust and security,
yesterday. About these documents leaked by the
whistleblower that was exposed on 60 Minutes are
unveiled on 60 Minutes. The interview is
fascinating because Neil Potts doesn't really deny
any of the claims, doesn't really deny any of
the substance of what the whistleblower alleges,
but instead seems just sort of shaken, almost
like he didn't expect. These were the questions
that were going to be asked. He deflects
using odd language. This is sort of a clinic
in, not in how not to do crisis management.
So let's just jump right in and listen here.
Speaker 2: And Facebook over and
over again chose to optimize for
its own interests, like making more money.
Speaker 3: We'll know that the company is
among NPR's financial supporters, and
we're joined now by Facebook executive
Neil Potts. He is vice president for trust
and safety. Welcome to all things considered.
Speaker 1: Buckle up
Speaker 4: here.
Hey Ari, how are you, Neil? Thank you.
Speaker 3: All right. Good to have you here.
So how can I explain Facebook's calculus this
way? If the company changed the algorithm to
make people safer and deprioritized hateful
and divisive posts than people would spend
less time on the site, click on fewer ads, the
company would make less money. Do you agree
that polarization leads to engagement,
which translates to money for Facebook?
Speaker 1: So the argument here it's important
to understand and I'm not going to keep
interjecting. But the idea here is, although
Facebook publicly says we want a depolarize,
we want to remove disinformation internally, they
know that that stuff generates clicks, which means
money so that in reality, they say one thing
publicly, but they encourage this stuff on the
Speaker 3: platform to money for Facebook.
Speaker 4: I think I would categorically deny
that I think that accusation is just a bit
unfounded as Facebook, what we are designing
our products to do is to increase it, to
increase meaningful experiences. So whether
those are meaningful social interactions. I think
that is the change that the leaker mentions in
her 60 Minutes interview or having just positive
social experience on the platform. That is what
we want the product ultimately to provide.
Speaker 1: Now, it's not unfounded in that
there are thousands of documents that
the leaker provided, which show the
opposite of what Neil Potts is saying the
Speaker 4: environment where people will
come to Facebook, where they will content
interest from and have a trustee at a better
time. And that's their bottom line.
Speaker 3: So I just want to be clear,
are you saying it may be the case? The
polarization leads to more engagement,
but we're not trying to polarize our users, so
that's not what we want the algorithm to do. Or
are you saying no? The premise that more extreme
views will lead people to engage more is just
fundamentally wrong.
Speaker 4:
I think it's just taking a step back on on that
question of polarization, I think polarization, as
you know, existed long before Facebook.
Speaker 1: So that's a deflection. OK.
The question's really specific. And and
Neil Potts. We didn't create polarization.
That wasn't the question, Neil, since long after.
Speaker 4: Perhaps we're we're all no longer here.
That being said at Facebook, we're not designing
anything to be for the sensational or clickbait
or engagement really ways that polarization
may be seen. And I think what was it being
accused of Facebook in the leadership,
Speaker 1: the guys making absolutely
no sense. I mean, it just seems completely
unprepared for what we're obviously going to be.
Speaker 4: The questions on the product are
probably designed to have more meaningful
social interactions, those interactions with your
friends, your loved ones. What does that mean?
Close knit groups can ensure that they're coming
to the platform to have a just a positive social
experience, one that you can have not only just
meaningful experiences, but things that you will
find perhaps unfettered on positive values.
Speaker 1: And you guys, I hope everybody
realizes this guy is making no sense
and answering none of the questions
Speaker 3: specifically about some of the
safeguards that were put in place after
in the run up to the 2020 election. These were
to reduce misinformation, and Horgan says many
of those protections went away after the election.
We now see indictments against some of the January
6th rioters that cite Facebook posts. So how does
Facebook to send defend its decision to dissolve
its civic integrity unit? Now that you know what
happened just after the election, when some of
those safeguards were no longer in place?
Speaker 4: Beautiful thing. Sorry, I think
I want to make sure that we're very clear here
in the Pacific and tell you it has not been
dissolved in any ways. Actually, it has been
in many ways promoted throughout the company.
The team is now sitting with other teams
so that we can take lessons learned.
Speaker 3: So this was a centralized team,
and now it's individual responsibilities
have been farmed out to other teams.
Speaker 4: It's still within our centralized
integrity.
Speaker 1:
I don't know that this guy says one thing that
we can actually take away that substantive.
Speaker 4: The broader team
to focus on other issues,
including civic integrity, but also issues that
Speaker 1: so so it's like what he's saying is the
team we had has not actually been disbanded. It's
just been broken up and they're now distributed
and working on different issues. Well. So
you've disbanded it, right? The people have
been separated and they're working on different
issues. And maybe also this one issue issues
Speaker 4: that are, I think, at the
top of everyone's mind, including
issues around health and COVID 19. You can see a
lot of the similarities between the way that we've
treated elections on the platforms, our elections
hub as well as we are doing around COVID 19 and
the COVID 19. So those teams are still in
practice doing work and actually working
on civic issues in election. The teams are
Speaker 1: still in practice doing work. Hmm.
Speaker 3: Let me turn to Instagram and how
it affects young people. Here's how Horgan
characterized the company's business
report last night on 60 Minutes.
Speaker 2: Facebook's own research says it is not
just that Instagram is dangerous for teenagers,
that it harms teenagers is that it is distinctly
worse than other forms of social media.
Speaker 3: And she says that research found
thirteen point five percent of teen girls
said Instagram makes thoughts of suicide
worse. Seventeen percent said it worsened
eating disorders. And when Congress asked
about this, CEO Mark Zuckerberg misstated
the company's research and then withheld
the damaging information that came out in
this leak. How does Facebook justify that?
Speaker 4: I think Mark recalled any of the
research, I think one of the issues here, we're
very committed to doing research. We recognize
the value so we can close the gaps where we do
see gaps. But I want to put a bit of the context
of this research in the field as well.
Speaker 1: It just goes absolutely.
We're committed to doing research to close gaps.
Yeah, but that's not what the question was about.
Speaker 4: This research was done over
a four boys and girls of teenage years
over 12 different areas and the majority actually
the majority of respondents were both boys and
girls. So that Facebook has Facebook and
Instagram have a net positive on there.
Speaker 1: And of course, that's also
a deflection, because the point is
many things for most people aren't negative. But
if something is negative for a lot of people,
it still matters and it's still important.
So. Neil Potts not prepared answering nothing
of substance. And we're going to continue
to follow what the fallout is from this,
both from the outage and from the whistleblower.
I want to remind you Tuesday, October 19th at 6:00
p.m. Eastern, we'll be doing a David Pakman
show live town hall. It will be exclusively
streamed on the new David Pakman Show YouTube
channel Pacman Live, which you can find at
YouTube.com. Slash Pacman Live, get subscribed
there in advance of the live town hall. Find
me on Twitter. Let me know what you think about
this Facebook stuff. I'm at Pacman on Twitter.